hello I'm Heather nullus and I was the
first machine learning engineer hired to
be on the AI team at t-mobile I'm going
to talk to you a little bit about how we
actually use our in production at
t-mobile in the steps that you can do to
do it as well because I know that nobody
loves handing off their beautiful code
to somebody else to just rewrite it and
Python and so what do we actually do our
goal is not to build a chatbot when you
hear lots of organizations talk about
doing natural language processing in
real time you think chatbots
by our goal is to essentially build a
tool that the customer can interact or
that the agent can interact with to help
customers so I have a little screenshot
of a sample of a tool that we have that
if somebody says hello I'm travelling to
Europe and I need to make sure my phone
works we run it through an intent model
we say you're talking about unlock so
let's go get some account information
about this individual that the agent
will need to help you and then let's do
an information retrieval and see
internal Wikipedia articles that the
agent could look at to service this
customer really quickly so the goal here
is not again to build chat BOTS and put
something in front of the user it's to
build tools that actually help the agent
help you faster and so I said I'm gonna
talk about putting are in production but
what does that actually mean
it's basically whenever you're sitting
on your computer you're working on our
markdown file you're doing an analysis
you run your code once to get the result
then you build it and that's code that's
continuously running anybody could come
up to your laptop at any time and see
that that code is running putting it
into production means putting it
somewhere that's outside of your laptop
where it lives all the time and that
users can always interact with it it's
always on it's always running and so I'm
piggybacking off of Jacqueline's
presentation yesterday we're gonna take
the pet name generator the big
tensorflow
deep learning model that she created and
we are going to put it into production
in my talk so if she handed me this code
what are the things that I would have to
do to make it actually run scalable
at t-mobile and so we do this with api's
and people say API all the time and it
sounds really intimidating but all an
API is is
every time that you go to a website on
your phone you are hitting an API an API
is just a way of getting information
from the internet instead of from a
console so you guys hit api's all the
time and there are two ways that people
primarily hit api's every time that you
go to a website that's a get request
you're saying whether com please tell me
what information I want to see like I
want to get the weather of the day or
you can do a post request which would
just be like I want to add my name to
your website I want to sign up for a
mailing list so here's my name website
do whatever you want with it and so a
get request is just going to a website
or getting any information from the
Internet and so for us what that means
is that we need to convert the variables
that it sends to us so our can use it we
need to make a prediction on those
variables and return the result and
that's it so if you remember yesterday
where we left off with Jacqueline she
had created a nice function that was
just to returned a bunch of predictions
so in this case I would say I want to
get twenty pet names and then the model
would run and generate twenty pet names
and then it would give it back to me and
that's all an API is so when engineers
say and they talk really lofty they're
all lying to you it's not that
complicated and we do that with plumber
which is a package developed by our
studio that is literally the easiest
thing in the entire world
so it is I'm not kidding it takes these
three lines of code and that's all it
takes to make what Jacqueline put on the
screen yesterday into an API so all you
have to do is import plumber show
plumber where the endpoints are and all
endpoints are are what comes after the
slash so if I went to weather.com slash
seattle the endpoint is seattle right so
it's just a part of the URL so you just
have to say what are the things after
the slash open a port to the Internet
which means that anybody can talk to you
import plumber and you've done it you've
built an API so when engineers make this
sound really complicated it's three
lines of our code anybody here can do it
so like I said you first you just create
a file for the endpoint so if you look
here it just says I want I'm going to
use a get function and I want to get
names return the this is exactly the
function that Jacqueline built yesterday
to just return many names xx
then we do the import and then you go to
the website on your computer and it
returns a result so it's like incredibly
easy you just run your function go to
the actual port that you open to the
internet and then you feel super
powerful because you did a thing that
engineers brag about doing and say that
you can't do an R all the time but six
lines of code I build Java services and
this is way easier and we really love
plumber like I always say that shinier
plumber should really be like I should
be giving them an award because they're
paying for my house at this point and
and to really to really demonstrate that
I have a totally unprompted sample of my
son who is 16 months old at the time he
always asked me what's on my laptop and
so here's an example of how much in my
family we love plumber amber who is it
plumber yeah it's our my 16 month old
child who only knows like slide and agua
also knows what plumber is because
that's how important plumber is to me
and so you built it it lives on your
laptop you have an API and haters say
your API sucks because you have to be
your laptop has to be connected to the
Internet you have to be running your
code and you have to just have it there
waiting for them and that's a hassle
nobody wants to live their life like
that just having their laptop waiting
for some probably jerk to be like can I
please access your model so we're gonna
put it in the cloud which is again
another thing that engineers say what
does it mean and so all the cloud is our
giant laptops in the sky that somebody
else owns and it's literally it so if
you have it on your laptop sitting there
you can put it on somebody else's laptop
you know all the steps to do that so
what would we need for our API that
Jacqueline built to work we just need an
operating system the correct version of
our all of the libraries that you think
that you need what you just wrote
there's three little lines of code and
everything that Jacqueline showed you
yesterday and then just open a port to
the Internet and so we've already done
that on our laptops so let's talk about
how we would do that in the cloud it
would be exactly the same you would
install our studio you would go through
the exact same steps that Jacqueline did
yesterday and you would do my last two
slides super super easy to do on a
virtual machine which is somebody else's
Skyloft
the downsides of using a virtual machine
is laptops are expensive right like -
every time that you get a new laptop and
you have to set it up it takes the quite
a bit of time to do that the company's
paying you that time to like reset up
these sky laptops it takes a lot of time
the setup is probably undocumented I
have a file of like all the special
things when I get a new computer that I
want to put on my computer but as you
know you probably have to install a
bunch of weird JavaScript plugins all
the time and then you forget that you
use this one package and you have to
reinstall everything so that's all
undocumented so if you were to leave the
company they couldn't recreate your
computer if somebody turned off your sky
computer they couldn't recreate it and
so since good engineering is repeatable
that probably isn't good engineering to
just set up a virtual machine so what
can we do that is super super repeatable
and how can we document this and that's
all containers are people talk about
containers they talk about docker the
containers are cheaper there is less
computational overhead because you don't
need to use a whole computer every time
they're super trendy so people think
that you're doing really cutting-edge
technology when you talk about it
they're made to crash and be restarted
so every time that you restart your
computer it takes forever to restart a
docker container takes microseconds and
then scaling and coordinating is easy so
I can say this docker container is out
there living but I started up this one
and let's just redirect traffic so I can
just my old models here my new models
here let's just switch where it's
pointing and that's all kubernetes is if
anyone's ever thrown that word at you is
just how do we tell which container
we're pointing at again not super
complicated jargon heavy and so all that
docker is is the repeated steps that you
need to set up a virtual machine the
repeatable steps were if I was to give
you a laptop and say write down
everything that you need to run my API
on your machine we just write it so a
computer can do that so we don't have to
have people sitting there forever while
our studio downloads for the 89th time
because I'm really bad at building
models and I need to play 89 times
before one works and so what this means
is that you can run docker on Kure you
can run your R code on computers that
don't have our installed because you've
installed it in the container and the
container lives on the computer
you can take it to your mom's house and
be like mom run this really cool code on
your computer and you don't have to run
her through all the ridiculous setup
steps at the end of the day I t's kind
of like your mom they don't want to do
all those little steps and they don't
care about what you're actually doing
they just want it to work and then you
no longer have to worry about package
management because doctor goes ahead and
takes care of all of that for you you
never have to worry about if you install
a certain hour package just it breaks
somebody else's code because you put it
in a nice little container that contains
it and keeps it from breaking everybody
else's stuff and that's really where the
name comes from but what does that look
like so we have a docker file and like I
said that's just the list of
instructions that would be used to set
up your computer at any time do you have
the image which is after somebody builds
that docker file and sets up the
computer like you want that's the image
and when you run it that's the container
so people will throw these words at you
a lot but they're all really the same
things just in different forms of the
process now I need my prop thank you and
so this is the pet names docker file for
the API that Jacqueline built in her
talk yesterday and so we just have a
starting image which we use rocker which
is just an our docker image and then
there are some Linux libraries we have
to import Python because Kerris runs on
Python let me copy over our scripts
install our libraries open up the port
and then just say run the main function
but there's a trick when you look at
this the first thing that it says is
rocker Version three point whatever but
what does that look like well that's a
lot of code and it actually it's it's a
lot a lot of code and so a good way to
think about docker images is to think
about nesting dolls
so the first image that I showed you let
me go back this is kind of your finished
product but that from line you kind of
open it up it says okay okay so it's
built on something simpler somebody else
did a lot of work so this is the next
image you say okay sure but that also
has an import line it's from Davian
which is an operating system so you go
and look at it and you like okay so now
we have a level smaller even and then
you say ah what's this there's another
one so you've got to open it you're like
okay so finally finally we've reached
the end
and so this is what you're doing every
time that you make a container which is
what makes darker so reusable is that
I'm able to say this is Davian build on
top of that now I have some other thing
and then you know if you build on top of
that then it's somewhere in there you
get the picture as so you can just take
all this stuff that other people are
building that's much simpler and say add
my little specific things add my more
details and make it more beautiful so at
the end really you just have to say look
at my beautiful finished product but
you're leveraging like thousands and
thousands of lines of code that other
people wrote for you
so then to actually run your container
you just on your computer is where you
would run it first just to make sure it
works so you can install darker on your
computer then open the console build the
image and run it and it would run
exactly the same as it did in our studio
but now you can do that on a computer
that doesn't have our install and so
what's left you've done all of this work
you've put your thing in a docker
container engineering departments are
really impressed DevOps is like I
understand what you're doing now and I
take our seriously there are a few
things that you have to think about you
have to think about how can you encrypt
your API it's to make it super secure
how can you add logging so that way
DevOps is happy with you how can you
write unit tests to prove that your code
is working and not absolutely broken and
is returning as expected and those are
things if you want to talk about those
three things I can talk about them to
you forever like forever and ever and
ever and ever my background is software
engineering and this is really all we do
at the end of the day but then you need
to release your code which just means
put it out into the world that way
people get to play with it and how we do
that at t-mobile is we have a very
complicated software engineering
pipeline so when you check something
into bitbucket which is like our github
when you check something in a fellow
named Jenkins builds the image for you
which is just going through this docker
file steps and setting up the machine
just like you act asked and then
marathon which is like cheap kubernetes
does the does the release so it puts it
out somewhere onto the internet and then
made those just hosts the container so
that's the website where it would
actually live but you guys don't have
time for that that's that's a lot that's
a lot of engineering so you can just do
it on AWS there's a thing called elastic
container store an elastic container
repository I believe and if you just go
to AWS you could say here's my docker
image they will build it for you
and they will host just that image it
will automatically get more recent
sources whenever you need it so if a ton
of people are hitting your employee
it'll say okay let's make this bigger
and if nobody ever uses your API that
you spent forever building despite the
fact that you've spent forever building
it it'll just say we'll quietly turn
that off which is fine because it's
really fast to turn onto docker
container as I said earlier so that's
the easy route elastic container storage
super super-great
and so this really works this is a
docker like this is exactly how we
productionize this for our consulting
firms website so right now you could go
to pet snowless llc.com slash names and
it will return you the stuff that
jacqueline built yesterday because
either exactly the steps that we went
through please don't hit it all at once
because we don't have auto scaling on it
because we are incredibly cheap but
anybody at any point could go and use
this and so Jacqueline didn't mention it
yesterday but when we first made the
deep learning container that generated
these pet names we shopped it around to
a lot of shelters in the Seattle area
and we were like please it'll be so
funny you guys deep learning is so funny
on the internet and the Internet will
think you're cool please name your pets
this will create a cute little image
people on Twitter will love it and by
and large you know shelters don't get
the joke they're like we we clean up cat
poop all day we really don't care about
this fancy technology that you've
applied but if you know a shelter who
wants to name their their animals some
deep learning names we have a thing that
you can have any point and sell our
project for us anybody can use it for
free if you name your pet after any of
these names generated by our neural
network I will give you a whole dollar
it really works it's super cool I love
it
and so the takeaways are that the stuff
that engineers talk about as being so
complicated really isn't and working on
the first project at t-mobile where we
really had data scientists and engineers
and machine learning people on a room
side-by-side it taught us that the
disparities between the two disciplines
are actually very small and so if you
guys can build a really complicated
model which you all can you can
absolutely add logging it's one line of
code you can create an API it's three
lines of code you can deploy an API
docker is really just writing down the
steps that you already do every single
time that you install something on your
laptop so this is stuff that you can do
is to stop letting engineer
people take away your work unless you
find this terribly boring then pretend
you can't do it yeah you don't have to
let engineers take away your work you
can leverage your company's engineering
department you could just throw it up on
AWS and it it all that's out the same so
I say thank you for sitting and
listening to me tell you about how much
I love docker again if you want to talk
about any of this for any length of time
I absolutely went to double extra thank
you to my son who allowed both of his
mom's to be here today instead of
hanging out with him especially it's
Mother's Day weekend and then the code
is available on github for the whole
thing so Jacqueline's neural network
down to docker izing it is all available
on the nola LLC github and you can
follow me on twitter at Heather class I
talk about engineering a lot thank you
you